alors bien sûr attentif à ces derniers
développements les étudiants se
préparent toujours à leur manifestation
de demain il devait écouter ce soir
j'imagine avec beaucoup d'attention
monsieur mitterrand c'est un mouvement
qui se veut calme demain et qui tente
ans qui entend dénoncer avant tout la
répression avec quand même le show
froide de plusieurs syndicats qui au
terme d'une valse hésitation ont décidé
ce soir de se joindre au mouvement c'est
vrai par exemple pour la fen et pour la
cfdt le point tout de suite yauba
grégoire ce matin à jussieu à la
coordination nationale on appelait à une
manifestation du souvenir à une
manifestation de la vigilance de main
dans les rues de paris et aussi de
province souvenir de malik et puis celui
de la violence face à un mouvement
contestataire qui se voulait pacifique
vigilance aussi sur l'avenir des
universités
puisque le gouvernement entend
maintenant ouvrir le dialogue un bureau
a été désigné pour la première fois
mardi dernier si le bureau de la
coordination a décidé de maintenir la
journée de mercredi c'est pour exprimer
dans le plus grand calme l'idée suivante
plus jamais ça
plus jamais de projet devaquet ou de
projet x med de vaquer plus jamais de
répression morts blessés lorsque la
jeunesse manifestent dans le calme et la
sérénité pour sur l'avenir c'est
apparemment ces slogans qui ont fait
basculer la décision de la faim ni la
cfdt ces deux organisations al'inverse
de la cgt avait annoncé qu'elle ne
participerait pas à la manifestation
finalement elles seront présentes demain
la fenière au bureau fédéral a appris en
cours de journée que monsieur chirac
retirer le projet devaquet à partir de
là la fin était amené à dire très
clairement elle ne lance plus son mot
d'ordre de grève générale de tous les
personnels ication et par ailleurs elles
ne participent pas à la manifestation du
10 dans les conditions où elle était
prévue par contre elle est prête à
participer à toute manifestation
concernant la défense des droits de
l'homme et en mémoire des victimes de la
répression
fo cgc cd